a new bromance for North Korea's Kim
jong-un pictured this week inspecting
his warplanes ahead of a trip to Russia
to meet with President Vladimir Putin a
journey also made by his father Kim
jong-il when he was in charge the summit
comes as relations cool between chairman
Kim and president Donald Trump a
newscaster announcing the testing of a
new but undisclosed weapon possibly a
short-range missile a provocative move
prompting China to nudge them to make up
the process of political settlement on
the Korean Peninsula is currently at a
critical stage we must work hard and
urge all parties concerned especially
North Korea and the u.s. to get along
with each other
president Trump and his North Korean
counterpart had appeared keen on a deal
to end Pyongyang's nuclear ambitions in
return for US sanctions relief but their
last meeting here in Hanoi ended
abruptly and without agreement Chairman
Kim
now turning up the heat in a high-stakes
war of words and posturing
this week's weapons test was not of a
long-range missile like this one but it
came with an attack on US Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo with North Korea
calling for him to be replaced in talks
for someone more mature Donald Trump has
yet to respond we may well see quite a
lot of drama around the summit with
President Putin scheduled I see now for
late April we can't be sure though that
if that summit does go ahead that it
will go the way that the North Koreans
want in the end President Putin is there
to defend pro Rutter's interests not
those of North Korea preparations for
the summit appear to be underway a
senior North Korean official pictured
inspecting sites in Russia
perhaps Moscow wants to help Washington
work for peace with Pyongyang or maybe
this meeting will shore up an old
friendship between two former Cold War
allies against a former Cold War foe
Deborah Haynes Sky News